okay let's see hi
i'm alan kim i'm here to take a quiz so
buzzfeed can guess my age
which of these animals is your least
favorite
dog cat zebra octopus
peacock and octopus i just don't like
them
how many pairs of shoes have you bought
this year
one two three four five six plus
six how many shoes have i got oh
okay three which of these smells are the
best
smell freshly ground coffee green
fresh bread gasoline baked cookies
ocean i'm guessing baked
cookies because the baked cookies make
such a great scent
and which of these smells is the worst
smell
vomit poop fish sour garbage
bad meat it's poop poop smells so bad
so i don't like it what time do you
typically wake up
five a.m six am seven am eight am
nine am other nine a.m it's because like
9am that's the most earliest time i wake
up
the latest time around 11 or 10
pick a cheesy food or chocolate food mac
and cheese
brownie grilled cheese chocolate cake
pizza ice cream sandwich that's a hard
one i want to choose them all
i choose pizza because it's just so
delicious and it comes with different
flavors
there's also ice cream pizza so
what's your first vowel and your last
name
a e i o
u w i i choose i because
my last name is kim and it's about k-i-m
if you had to be a bug what kind would
would you
be b and no way an ant
dragonfly i guess those are cool spider
never centipede never
i guess that's fine but i would choose a
dragonfly because
i like dragonflies a lot well i mean
ants
i don't like them whenever i see a
spider or egg
this is what i do if it's in my house
die
die die i just don't like ants or
spiders
i mean centipedes they look creepy
i mean they're endangered so i would
kind of
be like i wouldn't want that the ladybug
i mean they're small so they could be
her without people noticing lastly
here are some of the very common fears
which scared you most deep water
i love that heights i don't love it but
it's fine
small spaces what's wrong with that
public speaking
kind of needles yeah spiders
i feel like spiders is the best answers
i just scream when i see the spider
and i just get a tissue and be like
you got 25 years old
i'm eight why was
it's like 17 years away
i mean i guess it's wrong i feel my age
thank you buzzfeed make sure to watch
minari
bye
you